I'll play overwatch every now and then
it'll always be some guy in there with
like his twitch handle and he'll be
talking in a way and with the cadence
and like he'll be doing a voice like and
I know he's got like 14 Watchers on
Twitch oh that's interesting I yeah so
you can tell when dudes are streaming
that you're playing it like their voice
like I can tell if they're like if
they're doing a little too much I assume
these guys got to be streaming so then
what I actually enjoy it is blurting
super racist [ __ ] so that is brown
people need to go back it is your boys
chairman for here and sorry about that
racist comments there that was not me
that was someone I'm playing against
well Miller so I'm just gonna go ahead
and fully um get myself in trouble
not really no they actually did that
once so there was a girl streaming and I
didn't mind I didn't care you know but
then how did you know she was streaming
because she had like her twitch handle
on her thing and so some people will
actually put their twitch handle like in
their name or like they announced like
I'm streaming this girl particularly
announced that she was streaming because
someone said something that was like I
don't know they're like I'll [ __ ] you
[ __ ] and she's like whoa chill out I'm
streaming here like and I was like whoa
you you decided to do that so know what
yeah on us yeah no one here has to a
video game
yes yeah this is UK this is you know
this is a Wild West you can say whatever
the [ __ ] I mean you shouldn't like in my
experience kids do not be called a
[ __ ] a million by everyone so two
things about video games actually now
that we're in it so this time when she
did that I didn't like that she was
trying to police the language so I just
like started I hadn't spoken the whole
game so I just started doing a character
and I'm like I don't know why a girl's
in here playing a character that's not a
girl she's like that's not right I'm
like boy should pick boys girls should
pick girls this is how this is how video
games work [ __ ] go viral I know right
she cut that part out on YouTube and
everyone
yeah yeah so then you know she's like
she's like trying to skirt around it and
she was like talking over me this is a
LK buddy chill out and then I just
started going oh no you chill out I just
started you know screaming [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and just
ruining my brand deal yeah what the hell
I'm like this is not our problem so I
just start you know messing around and
then eventually she just kind of goes
quiet and I'm sure she'll cut that out
and be like more evidence of online
bullying but it's like no and chauvinism
and like whatever but I'm like you're
not denying that exist I'm just saying
it's funny too like yeah I'm that
content sleeve like people like this
exists well that person specifically
doesn't exist yeah number two you can't
just go in videogames and just tilt okay
boys we're not gonna curse anymore all
right it's like we're not your kids yeah
[Music]
these are gusting home
[Music]
all in my bag all of my wrists all of my
[ __ ]